Democrat darling Alexandria Ocasio
Cortez calls capitalism irredeemable and
America garbage we will examine why AOC
is wrong about everything
then the dirtbags at Media Matters try
to take down Tucker Carlson the mag a
hat smirking kid is suing CNN for 250
million and Captain America or what is
the new one Captain Marvel
yeah whatever then whatever Marvel movie
number 752 is is terrible even by
Marvel's standards I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
I hated that movie so much I couldn't
even remember its name lots to get to
we're talking about AOC because a OC the
thing I'm very grateful to her for is
that she makes abundantly clear what the
left actually believes which is that
capitalism is irredeemable in America is
garbage but we will explain why she gets
that exactly backwards actually it's
every other economic system that is
irredeemable unsupportable immoral we'll
get to that in one second but first
let's make a little money honey would
Express VPN then admit it you think that
cybercrime is something that happens to
other people it happens to everybody but
you right no one wants you or dad
hackers can't grab your passwords and
credit card details except that you're
wrong
stealing data from unsuspecting people
on public Wi-Fi is one of the simplest
and cheapest ways for hackers to make
money when you leave your internet
connection unencrypted you might as well
be writing your passwords and credit
card numbers on a huge billboard for the
rest of the world to see that's why I
decided to take action to protect myself
from cyber criminals I use Express VPN
expressvpn secures and anonymizes your
internet browsing by encrypting your
data and hiding your public IP address
if you are watching or listening to this
show
chances are you look at some pretty
weird stuff on the internet you don't
want that getting out you don't want
your employers to find out turning on
expressvpn production takes only one
click it's less than seven bucks a month
rated the number one VPN service by
TechRadar comes with a 30-day money-back
guarantee it is very very inexpensive
and very very valuable don't be
Pennywise and pound-foolish here protect
your online activity today find out how
you can get three months free at Express
VPN dot-com / Michael mi CH AE l that is
e XP ar e SS VPN comm slash Michael for
three months free with a one-year
package visit expressvpn comm slash
michael mich a e L Alexandria Cassio
Cortes was down at South by Southwest
over the weekend we saw a lot of great
clips from
the nice thing about her frequently
wrong but never in doubt she just says
exactly what she's thinking she sounds
like she's a freshman in college just
whatever ideas pop into her mind as
though she's just discovered them here
is a OCS take at South by Southwest at
maybe the pinnacle of capitalism the
most obvious decadent luxurious festival
or we can talk about all the wonderful
fruits of capitalism
she decides to that that is the occasion
to mention why capitalism is
irredeemable capitalism isn't to me is
it's an ideology of capital
it puts capital the most important thing
is the concentration of capital and it
means that we seek and prioritize profit
and the accumulation of money above all
else and we seek it at any human and
environmental cost that is what that
means and to me that ideology is not
sustainable and cannot be redeemed this
is that moment in 11th grade class where
you didn't do the reading and then the
teacher calls on you and you're going
for it and you're gonna keep a straight
face
yes Alexandria what is capitalism sorry
what was question Alexandre just like in
our reading last night what did what in
our reading said capitalism it's okay
capitalism yet capitalism is you know
capitalism is the economic theory we're
with the capital I'd say mostly it's
about capital a lot a lot of capital you
know and it's very much not about not
capital so things that are not capital
like morality or waffles or giraffes
like things that are not capital it's
like not no not that but capital yeah
that's cap that's what I would say
capitalism is that's her it's not what
capitalism is her explanation is not
correct - or is the fish
by any standard capitalism I think a lot
of people are confused on this I mean
we're hearing these surveys come out
that over fifty percent of young
Americans oppose capitalism and the
supportt socialism and it's because they
don't know what capitalism is capitalism
essentially is property rights that's
what it boils down to some people think
it boils down primarily to the free
market or the invisible hand or some
phrase that they learned in high school
no it really essentially boils down to
property do you have the right to own
and possess something or anything if you
have the right to private property this
implies a capitalist system private
property rights and now who would oppose
private property rights communists would
socialists would I guess Alexandria
cassia Cortes does but moral people
don't oppose property rights nobody can
make a moral argument really against
private property and why do we have a
right to property we have there are a
few competing theories as to why we have
a right to private property there's the
labor theory this is the John Locke's
view of property rights it's very
popular among libertarians that I I have
the right to property because I have the
right to my own labor
I have the right to the fruits of my
labor which is sort of true but not
really true like for instance if I'm a
winemaker I'm a laborer or at a vineyard
and I make wine I press the grapes and I
make wine out of that I don't have the
right to the wine because it because I
have the right to my labor but I don't
have the right to the grapes I don't
have the right to the field I don't have
the right to the presses I don't have
the right to any of the other things
that are necessary to make wine so I
have the right to my wages for making
the wine in that sense I have the right
to the fruit of my labor but I don't
have the right to the things that are
made with my labor another theory is the
legal right is the legal theory of
property which is that if the state says
you have a right to property then you
have a right to property again this is
pretty insufficient this would be Thomas
Hobbes's theory of it
probably and and that isn't really
defensible lettuce so you see how that
breaks down like for instance once
Alexandria Cassio Cortes runs your
government there is another theory
called the personality theory of
property which is that I guess this is a
little closer to it which is that
private property is essential to
individuality it's essential to the
development of the human mind which
requires things in order to you're to
have individuality to develop that your
human mind you need certain things and
in order to have things you need to have
the right to have things so that's close
it's a little vague though obviously the
real reason the actual defence the moral
defence of private property is a
biblical argument it's a very basic
moral argument which is that thou shalt
not steal that's why that's why we have
a right to property is because thou
shalt not steal thou shalt not steal
presumes that someone has property and
you have your own property or maybe you
don't have your own property but you
even if you don't have your own property
you can't steal somebody else's property
just because you want it and furthermore
thou shalt not cover it
thy neighbor's Goods even if you really
want his oxen you cannot covet that oxen
that's wrong these are the arguments
against or rather I suppose they're the
arguments for private property and
against taking private property away
from people Pope Pius the tenth in 1903
put this very clearly he said quote
unlike the beast man has on earth not
only the right of use but a permanent
right of ownership and this is true not
only of those things which are consumed
in their use but also of those which are
not consumed by their use so it's not
just that you have the right to own a
cherry pie or a cigar which is eaten and
burned you have the right to own
instruments of capital you have the
right to own a computer you have the
right to own leftist ears tumblr to
store your safely store your leftist
tears he goes on he says quote private
property is under all circumstances be
it the fruit of labour fruit of lay
being the the wages that you receive for
your labor or acquired by conveyance or
a donation a natural right and everybody
may make such reasonable disposal of it
as he thinks fit this is what it comes
down to private property is a natural
right for AOC to say that capitalism is
irredeemable is to say that private
property is irredeemably do you you
can't morally defend private property
but quite to the contrary you can't
defend an economic system without
private property that is indefensible
private property is a natural right our
country speaks very highly of natural
rights the right to life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness which demands the
ability to own property civilization
would be impossible without private
property you know that the pilgrims
found this when they came to America on
the Mayflower there were sort of
communists in the first couple years
after they landed and they quickly found
out that it would lead to starvation and
men wouldn't work aventure Bradford
wrote about this he said men don't want
to work under the communist system they
just lay about all day because they
don't want to work for another man's
benefit and so quickly he learned that
we needed to institute some private
property they divvied up land in a
private way all of a sudden production
flourished why else no family could
exist without private property to have
it what is if having a family you'd have
some say over your family's affairs you
need to provide shelter you need to
provide food you need to provide
education all of those things require
money all of those things require
private property Society would break
down communist governments socialist
governments they say that they don't
like private property but of course that
we've never in practice we've never seen
a society get rid of private property
what happens in communist and socialist
societies they just steal the private
property from others and they
consolidated at the top that's what
happens in Cuba that's why the Castro's
are so rich it's not because the private
property doesn't exist it's that they
took all the private property so with
the ruling class didn't Venezuelans with
the ruling class did in the Soviet Union
that's what the ruling class
would do under AOC system she goes on to
call America garbage but first let's
think we the people holsters We the
People holsters will help you defend
your liberty and property
they make custom-made holsters all
produced in the USA they designed their
own holsters in-house means they don't
use any third-party molds for their
holsters instead they design every
unique mold in Las Vegas in order to
best fit each and every firearm
perfectly they even have their own 3d
design team which measures every micro
millimeter of their guns to ensure the
perfect fit their unique and intuitive
clip design allows for you to easily
adjust both the can't ride of your
holster so that it will fit comfortably
and securely at all times every holster
has adjustable retention it's signaled
with that click sound custom printed
designs in-house thin blue line thin red
line Constitution camo American flag
more each month we the people holsters
start at just 37 bucks apiece
every holster comes in a lifetime
guarantee ships free if it's not perfect
send it back for a refund
right now listeners of the Michael Nolt
show can go to We the People holsters
comm slash Knowles KO wles
enter promo code Knowles Kenda wles a
checkout get $10 off your first holster
that's as low as 37 bucks and shipping
is free and you get an additional 10
bucks off using my promo code you're
basically making money we the people
holsters comm slash Knowles KN o wles
enter the promo code Knowles cannon wles
a checkout get 10% off so aoc makes this
morally indefensible point that private
property the reality is actually the
opposite this has been acknowledged by
moral philosophers for all of history
going back to Aristotle then she decides
to take her argument up to 11 and calls
America garbage I think all of these
things sound radical compared to where
we are but where we are is not a good
thing and this idea of like 10% better
from garbage is shouldn't be what we
settle for it's like this like it feels
like moderate is not a stance it's just
an attitude toward life of like
she she is so so millennial just that
the way she talks she can't finish
sentences she can't complete a thought
so she just says oh oh kind of random
gesticulations and three words here in
three words there ding-dong what I want
a bing bang she sounds like a typical
rich kid that's actually what she sounds
like she's there in her nice custom or
you know designer clothing
south-by-southwest very decadent
capitalist festival she's sitting there
being interviewed she says oh you know
it's also terrible Oh Oh the ennui oh oh
it's just so ah it's so hard to find
good help these days
so I just it's like I need something I'm
really passionate about you know I just
excuse me I'll have a little a little
the Chablis is a little warm could you
get a little thank you oh it's just so
terrible I hate my life
this is what rich kids do this is why
rich kids all do drugs in the suburbs
because they don't they don't have any
real troubles they don't have any
struggle they don't have any sense of
something they're struggling for and so
they complain about how nice things are
they don't know how good they've got it
they don't know the value of a dollar
we know a OC grew up in relative
affluence she didn't take her studies
very seriously obviously she hasn't
worked terribly hard she didn't you know
she she worked she lived with her
parents according to voter records until
2016 yes she was working as a bartender
I don't know how many days a week and
then she's on the public dole now and
funneling money into private companies
and things like that for her own use
she doesn't value what we've got here
this is a problem with Millennials
especially those who grew up after the
Cold War because it has an attitude it
implies an attitude of easy come easy go
oh this up this civilization she didn't
work for this to quote Barack Obama she
didn't build that we've inherited this
fab
civilization this wonderful American
society where everything is really nice
and peaceful and rich and just lovely
and we say uh easy come easy go let's
try something totally different let's
just throw it all away it's it's that
Chesterton fence problem she gets up she
sees all of these American institutions
all these American ideas and she doesn't
know how they got there
she doesn't know why they're there she
don't tear it down I don't see why it's
there why is private property we don't
need Pro do we need that no I don't
think so
just tears it all down it's so
disrespectful it is this standing on the
shoulders of giants and thinking that
you're flying standing on the shoulders
of giants and spitting on them saying
who cares you didn't you're not so great
I'm so much better than you because I'm
a modern person I'm alive right now
garbage imagine that calling your
country garbage calling your countrymen
garbage when we say that the left hates
America this is what we're talking about
they protest the American flag they call
the country garbage her words not mine
then she goes on to explain why America
is garbage we should not be haunted by
the specter of being automated out of
work right we should have we should not
feel nervous about you know the
Tollbooth collector not having to
collect tolls anymore
we should be excited by that but the
reason we're not excited by it is
because we live in a society where if
you don't have a job you are left to die
and that is at its core a problem what
society is she living in gosh the
fantasy society in her head sounds
really awful fantasy America is a really
terrible place of course in real America
nobody is left to die as a matter of
fact anybody can go get health care and
illegal aliens go to the emergency room
all the time nobody is left to die in
America she says that if you don't have
a job you're left to die we have an
extraordinarily generous unemployment
insurance system we have extraordinarily
generous unemployment medical benefits
Medicare Medicaid all of these programs
not to say nothing of the civil society
to say nothing of charities that provide
these sorts of things but she says
people are left to die in America and
then think about the point on automation
she says look we shouldn't be upset if a
job gets destroyed because that that
means that you don't have to work
anymore isn't that great
then you don't have to work I mean this
is her doubling down in the green New
Deal the draft legislation says that
they will provide money for people who
are unable to work or unwilling to work
because I don't want to work for my keep
that's fine you're just gonna check
unwilling to work and then people said
oh she's being taken out of context she
didn't really mean that no she did she's
saying it right here unwilling to work
this what a good thing but when it also
misunderstands is the role of work
because we all joke you know sometimes
we're not joking we say oh my job is
killing me today oh gosh you know I've
I've been on the road for weeks I'm
hitting the road again
you know later I've got a headache for a
while I just some days you just don't
want to wake up and go into work except
work is a very good thing Adam worked in
the Garden of Eden consider that in
paradise man worked man is supposed to
work it is good for man to work what
would you do if you didn't work I think
it was Moliere who said it was Moliere
somebody said that hell is the place
where you have nothing to do but amuse
yourself all the time that is what hell
is I mean you know this if you have a
take a vacation for the first day you're
just like woohoo yeah you're just binge
watching Netflix you're drinking I don't
eat going out you're stuffing your face
and then by day four you just sort of
lazing around you're just like I don't
know what to don't know why I'm waking
up anymore
we have to it is good to work even if
you could tax the rich soak the rich
give everybody a free check that would
be worse for society this is why the
universal basic income is unhuman
and per se that's white is just wrong on
its face because it is bad not to work
is bad to incentivize people not to work
but how is alexandria cassia cortez
going to pay for everybody not to work
one of the reasons that this ideology or
questions of what do you want to call it
democratic socialism or techno futurism
are like whatever it is it is because
our technological advancement as a
society has outpaced our system for
handling finite resources because now we
are approaching approaching infinite
resources what this is this sounds like
that one of those late-night bull
sessions that you know you have freshman
year or when you're really hammered
that's what she sounds like she said you
know yeah man cuz because you know man
we're thinking in a finite world you
know fine but imagine if it were
infinite which is where we're going
we're not going by the way to an
infinite resources economy things in the
material world are finite this woman by
the way is 29 years old she has a
college degree theoretically it was she
majored in economics which is evidence
to decertify the bu economics program
we're not what does that mean
we're thinking in this minor you know
this kind of finite infinite finite no
no no she says that Bill Gates has an
idea we have the clip of her Bill Gates
idea there are a lot of different
solutions or a lot of different proposed
ideas about how we go about that you
know Bill Gates has talked about taxing
robots at 90% and what that means what
he's really talking about is taxing
corporations at 90% but it's easier to
say tax a robot so not really actually
it's no surprise alexandria casio cortez
doesn't know much about how taxation
works
she thought that a tax incentive was
just giving up
from a slush pile with regard to the
Amazon move into New York so she doesn't
know what taxes are what Bill Gates
means when he says we need to tax robots
is not that we're gonna tax corporations
we already tax corporations and we're
gonna continue to tax corporations and
until President Trump we had one of the
highest corporate tax rates in the world
what what it means to tax robots is to
tax capital investment right so you if
you're a business owner you've got your
money whatever your cash flow is
whatever investment you've got whatever
money you've got at your use you can put
it into one of two things
capital that is to say renovating the
store buying robots touchscreens at
McDonald's capital technology or labor
people you can hire more people you can
pay your people more you can whatever
capital and labor those are the two
places that you can invest your money so
when you tax the robots what you are
really taxing is capital investment so
what you are really taxing is automation
so what you are really doing is creating
an incentive to keep paying the
Tollbooth operator so what you are
really doing is the so where Alexander
aquezio Cortez began her argument is
don't worry about the Tollbooth operator
let the Tollbooth operator lose her job
we're gonna automate everything it'll be
great and how are you going to deal with
the Tollbooth operator oh we're going to
create economic incentives not to
automate anybody so that the Tollbooth
operator can keep her job you just said
it was good for the Tollbooth operator
lose her job now you're advocating for
economic incentives to let the tag and
Tollbooth operator keep her job all of
this all of this amounts to AOC not
really understanding very much about
economics this is no surprise so what
does she do she doesn't know much about
economics she doesn't know about the
moral arguments for this economic system
she can't make any economic arguments
for her own system which is socialism or
democratic socialism whatever she wants
to call it so then she pivots as they
always do when they can't make the
arguments that they're trying to make
they
pivot to a racial argument I think a
perfect example of how special interests
and the powerful have pitted white
working-class Americans against brown
and black working-class Americans in
order to just screw over all
working-class Americans is is reaganism
in the 80s when he started talking about
welfare queens he's painting this like
really resentful vision of essentially
black women who were doing nothing that
were sucks on our country right who said
black women hold on a second let me let
me rewind the clip I'm gonna go through
I have a little monitor over here of
everything Ronald Reagan has ever said
about welfare queens weird it can we
just go through every CEO you know oh
yeah you didn't mention black women you
mention black women alexandria casio
cortez mentioned black women that's the
subtle racism that's what is revealed
what she's saying is that when Ronald
Reagan says people who just sit at home
and don't work at all and just collect a
check from the government that's not
good and we should reform that what a Oh
see here's is oh it's just those black
woman's just those lazy blacks that's
what she hears but he never said that
she just heard it why did she hear it I
don't know maybe that's her own
prejudices or biases or bigotry or
whatever she is doing exactly what she
accuses Reagan of doing but then she
switches you'll you'll see the subtle
generational shift in the socialist
argument but for that you've got to
stick around go to daily wire.com ten
bucks a month one hundred dollars for an
annual membership you get me you get the
end of clave and show you at the Ben
Shapiro show you get to ask questions in
the mailbag you get the Matt Walsh show
you get to ask questions at backstage we
got one of those coming up you'll get
another Kingdom you get everything you
get the leftist here's tumblr you they
taste good all that you know what this
one tastes like this tastes like that
little smirking kid from Covington high
school you know the one with the mag
had it tastes like just 250 million
little CNN left his tears one after
another nice little lawsuit leftist
tears and and you're gonna have to get
multiple tumblers because you're gonna
need one for the Washington Post one for
CNN one for the New York Times one for
Ilan Omar one for all of these people go
to daily we're calm we'll be right back
with a lot more
so AOC is doing exactly which it uses
Ragan of doing she says that what Reagan
did was to pit white working-class
Americans against brown and black
working-class Americans
when did he do this I don't know never
saw it happened well the one example she
gives us welfare queens but welfare
queens are not in the working class
because they don't work I think to be in
the working class you have to work that
seems to be a very basic definition of
working class so she can't give any
example but she is using this racially
divisive language and she's accusing her
opponents of racial bigotry which is
what the left always does but this is a
subtle generational distinction back
when Bernie Sanders and Karl Marx were
inventing communism back you know in the
19th century they would sit together and
they would break down society only along
class lines so it was only the working
man the poor the industrial labor versus
the capitalists the rich guys whatever
this was good for a time this worked for
them for a spell but what
intersectionality managed to do was add
in all of the racial identity politics
as well and that's where a Oh C is so
it's no longer sufficient as Bernie
Sanders does to only talk about the poor
and the rich and to demagogue the rich
and to vilify the rich now you have to
go a little more particular and vilify
the rich white people you have to say
that the the rich white men or the rich
white straight men or the rich white
straight men who think their men you
have to get much much more specific why
is this more useful because by
definition you're getting to a smaller
minority this is the 99% versus the 1%
kind of rhetoric so when you get to that
smaller minority it's easy for everyone
to get behind it it's easy for you know
there was one time I was in DC I was
walking around DC and I walked by the
Hebrew Israelites those are those black
supremacists who were in the incident
with the Covington high school kids and
you know they're kind of a mains
stay in DC and New York you hear I'm
calling out you know you white devil and
you white this and and I was then in a
coffee shop and I hear these two girls
ahead of me say gosh those those black
Israelites they they called me a white
devil and they said that I'm an
oppressor cuz I'm in a white woman and I
said I said guys are you crazy come on
I'm a woman I've been oppressed - oh my
gosh oh no here we go she had the right
reaction which is her you ridiculous no
I'm not oppressed and neither are you
you're here in the richest country in
the world you almost certainly don't
work and yet you're very large people so
clearly you're eating just fine one of
the biggest problems among the poor in
America is they're too fat it's obesity
that's a first world problem everyone
has this lovely decadent sort of thing
you can stand here on the street
shouting your vicious remarks and
nobody's going to arrest you're nobody's
gonna stop you this is a pretty easy
society to live in that's the right
response but instead she has to take the
response and say oh no I'm a victim too
please let's gang up on the white guy
because we're on the same side buster I
mean that's that's what a Oh see that's
what intersectional politics are
convincing people to do but this is the
new generation this is what the new
Democrats are and there was a a comical
display of the old Democrats Howard
Schultz Colorado Governor John
Hickenlooper over the weekend they came
out they tried to make their case for
why they're they're better than aoc at
handling these issues it just falls flat
here's Starbucks CEO former Starbucks
CEO Howard Schultz in the green New Deal
there is a proposal that says that by
2030 every building in America is going
to be transformed to clean energy now
that's a well-intentioned idea but it's
never going to happen so my question to
the people who are proposing these
things is let's propose things that are
true that are honest that are sincere
and that are realistic just to put the
math in
in context that would mean that 2,700
buildings a day between now and 2030
would be transformed and the government
doesn't own those buildings said they
would have to mandate and the cost to it
yeah come on guys come on hey guys can't
we just look I'm on your side but can't
we did Howard Schultz is the girls in
line in DC Howard Schultz is is that
kind of that squish who says to the
lunatic to the bully who says I'm on
your side
no no I'm not look I'm on your side but
can't we just Howard Schultz is the kind
of guy who in college says look
communism is beautiful in theory it's
just that in practice it's no good no no
no no communism is terrible in theory
it's awful its anti human it's horrific
and wicked and evil the green New Deal
is terrible in theory it's not good in
theory maybe the people who wrote it
have good intentions but it's a very
terrible in theory it's a very terrible
thing to tear down every building in the
country within ten years and rebuild it
so that it runs on candy canes and
daydreams or something that's very
terrible why why is it so two people
because I like my home I don't want you
to tear down my home most people don't
want their homes torn down just because
you don't want them to use the air
conditioning why else well because we
have historic buildings in the United
States we have beautiful 17th century
buildings in some cases should we just
tear those down some of those beautiful
buildings from the 19th century just rip
them all to all the beautiful apartment
buildings in New York knock them down
historic mansions in the south knock
them down all those great on Bourbon
Street in New Orleans you know all that
knock them down what do you have left
you've knocked down your whole country
the White House knock it down
well you have to it's not it's not up to
AOC standards knock it down building
it's terrible in theory the green new
deal is off-limits your choice it takes
away your private property
I'm not saying
that we need to live in some libertarian
ridiculous fantasy utopia either that
obviously that's that's crazy to but we
right here today right now in reality
have private property we have a country
we have buildings we shouldn't rip that
all to the ground and Schultz thinks
that by feeding that crocodile by
appeasing that Alexandria Ocasio Court
says she's gonna eat him last by feeding
the radical socialist intersectional
left maybe he can compromise with it no
he's just a Neville Chamberlain like all
the rest of them then John Hickenlooper
he's uh he's he's running for president
or something maybe I don't know I got
like a Google Alert sort of and I guess
is that he's the governor of Colorado
who's probably not even gonna make it to
the first debate and he's gonna run on a
similar sort of thing this guy thinks
that by appeasing these radicals he'll
be able to eke his way to the nomination
he won't even say that he's not a
socialist you did an interview earlier
in the week where you were asked three
times if you would call yourself a proud
capitalist and you wouldn't directly
answer the question
it led Howard Schultz who's possibly
candidate to say if even a successful
businessman and entrepreneur like
governor Hickenlooper can't openly
support capitalism the Democratic
primary it's clear this is senator
Sanders party now why are you
uncomfortable calling yourself a proud
capitalist I've been at the point I was
making is that we defined people by
these labels that that often have all
kinds of associations and baggage with
them in that sense do I believe in small
business of course I believe in small
business I started probably more than
twenty different small businesses I'd
have you know in one year I'd have over
a million customers I understand that
but what's happening I think it's kind
of a silly question we should be looking
at some of the reasons behind why we
have less and less startups we should
look at are the reasons why you know
more and more people aren't wanting to
start a business oh that is
Oh pathetic this guy john hickenlooper
is a businessman but this is also your
evidence by the way that corporate
america the kind of Chamber of Commerce
Republicans they're just liberals
they're just left wingers because the
culture is left-wing and business just
wants to make money and they go along to
get along and they want to minimize
their exposure minimize their
vulnerabilities minimize their political
risk and so they just go along with the
leftist culture it's why you can't
really trust those guys to advance a
conservative agenda what he won't even
say he's not a socialist oh I just think
these labels are so silly what's the
point of all these labels the point of
labels is to let us know what you think
that's why we have words that's why Adam
in the garden going right back to Adam
in the garden one of his jobs there was
to name things to give things labels so
that we can discern them so that we can
differentiate between them the whole
process of creation is a process of
discrimination and discernment and
separation
separating the land from the sea
separating the light from the darkness
separately right separating these things
so that you can name them why do we have
a name for light and a name for darkness
I mean isn't that just silly no it's so
that we can identify it why do we why do
we it used her that's why we use words
politics is speech this has been true
since Pericles has been true since
Aristotle politics is meaningful speech
and politics is using speech to convince
people to persuade people to make
arguments to appeal to people's pathos
to appeal to people's to ethos to have
spirit to it to exhibit spirit to appeal
to people's logic logos that's what we
that isn't this is rhetoric right and
what Hickenlooper wants to do is weasel
his way to the Democratic nomination he
wants to be everything to everybody but
he can't stand up for anything why would
you ever vote for John Hickenlooper what
is just nothing John Hickenlooper in the
most important matters of the day would
you say that you're X or Y well I would
say I'm neutral
or is that gonna work no it's not gonna
work in the Democrat primary Kamala
Harris is the weathervane that's how you
know which way it's going Carmel Harris
is a cynical politician Willie Brown old
politician just admitted to cheating on
her cheating on his wife with her and
then launching her political career
because of that she is a tough lady
she's pretty sharp and she's gonna say
whatever she's got to say to get the
nomination in she she's the weather vane
she is moving left she actually endorses
the basic utopian leftist progressive
communists call it whatever you want
premise in a recent impromptu campaign
speech that we can change human
behaviors without much change our
lifestyle and we can save the future
generations world did you say that we
can change human behavior we can change
she's saying we can change human nature
is what she's saying this is the project
of progressivism or leftism is to change
human nature not just now you know might
not happen tomorrow but over time we're
going to fundamentally change human
nature and that is going to bring us to
utopia Oh what they seem to forget is
that utopia doesn't mean the best place
it means no place you topia means no
place it doesn't exist that is a
terrible idea you cannot change human
nature that's what makes it nature
that's what nature is and so when people
have tried to change human nature over
time it has resulted in unspeakable
human misery but she admits that's their
purpose we're not just taxing the rich a
little bit more we're not just
liberalizing certain social mores we're
not chitin oh no we are going to change
human nature that is their project
that's how ambitious that's how
dangerous the left's project is
and let me tell you Kamala Harris has a
much better chance of winning this
nomination than John Hickenlooper before
we go I have to say word about Tucker
Carlson Media Matters for America which
is a leftist assassination group
character assassination group they're
not actually going out there with guns
they just try to assassinate people's
characters it exists to get right wing
commentators taken off the air it exists
to censor right wing commentators that's
the whole purpose of Media Matters and
it is disingenuously referred to as a
media watchdog group in the mainstream
media it is not it is a hit squad from
the left to censor right wing
commentators because they were afraid of
what we have to say so they dug up some
footage of Tucker Carlson from 13 years
ago I think it is when he was calling
into a shock jock radio show and they
are trying to take him down over this
tape for that he didn't Warren Jeffs
didn't marry underage girls he's in
prison for facilitation of child that
means he's in prison because he's weird
and unpopular and he has this different
lifestyle that other people find he's an
accessory to the rape of children that
is a felony and a serious one at that
what do you mean an accessory he's like
got some weird religious cult where he
thinks it's okay to you know marry
underage girls but he didn't do it why
wouldn't the guy who actually did it who
had sex with an underage bro he should
be the one who's doing like okay what is
I don't even understand what I'm
supposed to be shocked and outraged and
offended by here
he's calling into a show what's the show
called like the love bunch something I
mean it's some ridiculous shock-jock
show and he's calling in and they're
saying provocative things to one another
and making jokes that's what this is
about
and Tucker Carlson makes the point that
you should be punished far more severely
if you actually have sex with an
underage girl than if you're just there
at the time right like if you're the
cult leader that it's bad to be a cult
leader I don't think Tucker Carlson
it's good to be a cult leader but it's
it's worse to have sex with an underage
girl and but I'm supposed to be really
offended or something and then oh they
were really upset about this one because
Tucker Carlson he said a naughty word
like sister where we run into her all
the time she seems like a shuffle yeah
they're very she seems extremely bird oh
yeah I'd step over me she seems why now
go ahead she just does seem a little you
said it I just agreeing with you I don't
use that word right I love for Tucker
Carlson tonight on MSNBC a girl that
comes across conic so the word I guess
you can't obviously here oh we bleep it
out it's a word that rhymes with punty
use your imagination and so the guy the
guy who was hosting the show he says
yeah she seems kind of punty wank and
then Tucker says yeah she does seem kind
of punty okay that that's what he said
because no one I'm sure no one at Media
Matters has ever used that word the
c-word nobody there has ever said it
have that no right none of them of
course not no now what they would say
what Media Matters would say is well I
think it's perfectly fine to call women
that word all the time but Tucker says
it's wrong but he did it one time so
right okay okay what a a he made a joke
with a guy one time on a shock jock show
okay cool dude also by the way at least
Tucker Carlson has standards which he
occasionally violates as we all do what
standards do you have Media Matters
these guys I haven't I mean there is no
first of all Tucker Carlson will not
lose even one viewer over this he will
not lose one no but I mean this is such
a disingenuous hit job against Tucker
Carlson but they're gonna try to get get
the right to lose their viewers this is
what they it's so weird because we don't
really do this we I don't really care if
Rachel Maddow has a show it's double
income for me I don't really care if joy
Reid has a show I care about the
hypocrisy I care that right-wingers are
losing their shows and left wingers or
not and that's what I care I don't know
I don't care if I don't know who Chris
Hayes I okay you can have a show I don't
watch it I'm not a lot of people watch
it anyway but that's
fine but they get they're so offended
because the left knows that they can't
beat us in an actual exchange of ideas
so they have to censor us they have to
shut us up it's awful these people are
awful Media Matters for America they are
just character assassins and it would be
a real shame it would be a real shame if
somebody went out and dug up some dirt
on
I don't Madeline pelts for instance
who's a public writer for Media Matters
for America or Christina Lopez gee you
know that would be real that's another
one of the authors public authors at
Media Matters or Eric hon and Cokie it
would be a real shame a damn shame if
someone went out and dug up some
embarrassing moments from 13 years ago
on any of those people would be a
wouldn't that be awful because then they
would get a taste of their own medicine
and they would realize why a graceless
society is so awful I would I would
mention a few more of the public writers
except I can't because the cowards at
Media Matters for America usually hide
behind an anonymous byline frankly at
least those three people put their names
on there on their hit jobs I'll actually
give them credit for that the rest of
them just hide behind anonymity would be
a real shame wouldn't it one of those
writers at Media Matters for America got
a little taste of their own graceless
medicine all right that's our show a lot
more to get to but too bad we're running
late I will see you all tomorrow in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy more senior producer Jonathan hey
our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jessa
of era production assistant Nick Sheehan
the Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19